for a few hours in May 2016 for the
first time in more than a century
Britain was burning zero coal to
generate electricity not at all all the
coal-fired power plants were turned off
and this here is one of the reasons why
welcome to the Griffin wind farm in
Scotland sixty-eight turbines more than
150 megawatts of capacity and the
turbines rotate and trim the blades to
track the wind in real time at full
output this can power entire cities just
from the wind but as the world moves to
renewable energy got a little bit of a
problem because coal oil gas nuclear
stations are basically just giant
boilers they take water they heat it up
that turns to steam the steam gets
forced to a massive turbine which
rotates and generates power want to say
turbine nothing like the blades here I
mean hundreds of tons of Steel rotating
thousands of times a second and all
those turbines all around the grid
rotate in sync with each other after
gearing they all move at 50 cycles a
second 60 in America all perfectly in
time one slows down they all slow down
one speeds up they all speed up and that
is what stops your light from constantly
flickering because electricity supply
has to always match demand pretty much
exactly there isn't a battery in the
world big enough to store power on a
national scale so if a power station
suddenly falls off the grid for some
reason then where's that supply going to
come from and the answer is the kinetic
energy that's already in those turbines
in that spinning thousands of tonnes of
Steel around the country homes and
factories will literally suck the
kinetic energy out of that turbine to
cover the gap starting to slow it down
but that won't cause a problem for 60
seconds or so and in that time the
National Grid control center will uh now
throw another nuclear rod on the barbie
and up the power output from other
stations look of the demand but well
that relies on having enough rotational
mass enough system inertia as it's
called and here in this turbine world
you can see there's no hundreds of tons
of spinning steel there's just some
blades bit of metal and some circuitry
that feeds the power into the
raid at the right frequency if the whole
grid were running on just wind and solar
then there's no rotational mass there's
no grid stability the minute that supply
and demand mismatch breakers would trip
and the whole thing would fall apart now
there are some possible solutions to
this pump hydro storage has been around
for a while which is where you have two
lakes at different heights when you've
got too much power you pump water up and
when you've got not enough you drop it
back down again through generators but
that takes seconds or minutes to kick in
there's also some experiments going on
with things like molten glass storage
compressed air storage and flywheels but
they're all experimental at the minute
in not particularly efficient the actual
solution may come from somewhere a
little unexpected because yes wind is
replacing coal and oil but it's also
replacing petrol the gasoline that you
put in your car and as more and more
electric cars get connected to the grid
well you've got a load of quite large
batteries with computers your car could
sell power back to the grid in real time
second-by-second as it's needed
combine that with smart appliances and
meters that can watch the grid and work
out the best time to turn on your air
conditioning and fridges and you have a
grid that does a lot of the balancing
itself yes we will probably always need
a turbine somewhere some big spinning
massive steel to cover the little
glitches second a second but the
solution to balancing a power grid is
not what we thought it was 20 years ago
it's not big monolithic batteries it's
millions of small ones up and down the
country thank you very much to all the
team from SSA who've helped get me and
my team up on top of this wind turbine I
am incredibly grateful they've done
above and beyond to help out so please
have a look at the links in the
description for more about them and
about the Griffin wind farm